قال الامين العام للنتنبرغ ان الرئيس
الروسي ليس مستعدا لاخذ خطوه باتجاه السلم
واشار سولتمبر الى ان انتصار اوكرانيا في
ارض المعركه هو الطريق الذي سيوصل الى
المفاوضات والحلول السلميه
ما نراه اليوم في اوكرانيا هو ان الرئيس
بوتين ليس مستعدا للسلم بل لمزيد من
الاعتداء والحرب نتطلع الى ان تنتهي الحرب
على طاوله المفاوضات واذا اردنا حلا سلميا
يجب ان ندرك ان ذلك سيتحقق بانتصار
اوكرانيا في ارض المعركه بمساندتنا علينا
ان نتعامل بالطريقه التي يفهمها بوتين
وعليه ان يتقبل ان اوكرانيا دوله ذات حريه
وسياده وتنتمي لاوروبا
لم نشهد حاليا تقديم اي مساعدات من قبل
الصين لروسيا لكن الصين ربما تخطط لتقديم
المساعده لروسيا وعليها الا تفعل لان ذلك
يعد مسانده لروسيا في حربها غير الشرعيه
على اوكرانيا هذه الحرب ليست شرعيه وتخرق
ميثاق الامم المتحده والصين عضوا في مجلس
الامن ولديها مسؤوليه في حماية هذا
الميثاق اما بشان المقترح الصيني فالصين
ليست لديها اي مصداقيه لانها لم تردد
بالغزو غير الشرعي لاوكرانيا كما انها
وقعت قبل ايام من الحرب اتفاقيه مع روسيا
لشراكه غير محدوده معها